hi I'm Greg I'm John John and Greg today
I got to talk about something boy
something something the matrix reboot oh
man oh yeah that's right the matrix
reboot now have you hear about this I
heard a lot about this when I first
heard about this I mean people have been
talking about like rumors of a reboot
for a long time like a couple of years
now and there's even one point where
there was a rumor going around the
counter it was like yeah we're
definitely doing a matrix for [ __ ]
from The Hollywood Reporter it's been a
lover movie news sites I'm sure you've
heard about you click on this video
you've heard about it I'm sure at least
one of your friends is bitched about it
or you've bitched about it to them in
the past few days the story's been
updated a little bit when it was first
announced that we're saying that there
that it looks like they wasn't confirmed
but the rumor was that it's gonna be a
reboot in the sense that it might be a
prequel specifically on Morpheus and
they were thinking of Michael B Jordan
as the new neo
there's all this is the main rumors that
were going around and when I heard
prequel I was like what no don't do that
that sounds horn oh I have knowing first
off I heard matrix true but I was
written and then I read about what they
what the rumor was I was like oh my god
it's just getting worse and worse this
is a terrible idea cuz I'm like what
well can you really explore with a
prequel I mean I feel like they probably
shouldn't even touch the matrix in
general I just don't feel like they
should I feel like the matrix is one of
those like flag like the matrix was a
big moment like that movie has been sort
of ingrained in culture the way few
movies get to be and if we were talking
about this the other day and I used like
Star Wars as a metaphor it's like that's
a big Titanic of a property and you can
strut it out but you gotta start it out
for the right reason cuz we're always
gonna get out to see it yeah I feel like
if you're gonna do the matrix first off
my option a would be just don't touch
the matrix because unless the which
house keys are involved I don't think
you should have anything to do with it
yeah it's like unless you have a good
reason less you have like a dynamiter
like this is not something I would ever
see just like gone back to so we could
bang out you know a few cool franchise
flakes because if it was a reboot or
remake all they would really do is just
give us updated action
idea over a new attack and I'm like a
the characters are such an important
aspect too I mean everyone like neo
Trinity Morpheus when I heard reboot
reboot or remake I was like why would
you do this without even the earth like
why would you even think you can get
away with doing that without the
original cast in there did they say that
they were gonna try to do that yeah that
was the first announcement oh so if
you're not gonna do the original cast
which is so silly to me because Keanu
Reeves is back on top with John wick in
action movies when people got jacked up
for the John wick to trailer a big part
of it was because they saw Laurence
Fishburne was in it - dude what if John
wick is just another Merovingian maybe
yeah I just don't think that the idea of
a reboot would be useful in any capacity
was that you would have anything worth
saying cuz like the matrix was cool
because the matrix also like made us
want to discuss it and like pick apart
the theories and the philosophies and
stuff like that this is a movie you got
a think hole what about the other thing
too is that the witch house keys are
such a significant part of what makes
the matrix the matrix I don't care what
you think of Speed Racer or Jupiter
ascending I'm not saying those are good
films but the matrix in terms of
philosophy and story everything about it
comes from the crazy weird minds of the
Wachowskis no one knows the world as
well as that matter and the fact that
there's been no announcement that
they're actually involved in it and is
getting me concerned that is a concern
yeah yeah definitely I would give it a
chance or whatever but I would be very
worried about a know which house key
involvement me yeah if they're not
involved in this story like in terms of
developing this story they don't have to
write the script but if they're involved
in developing the story and producing it
then I could get on board for a Matrix
movie but if the witch house keys are
not involved at all in the creative
process behind this film you see I don't
care what you even say about reloading
and revolutions cuz to me those films
get better than
i rewatch them I didn't like revolutions
the first time I saw it but as I watched
every time i rewatch the whole trilogy I
see that they really told one gigantic
story they told one complete story that
probably needed even another movie so
they didn't have to jam-packed a bunch
of exposition and revolutions to make it
work or a full architect scene to me
yeah so I felt like The Matrix films
they weren't I don't feel like they were
just cash-grab films maybe aspects of
them were but I felt like this sequels
the wait there's like the Wachowski is
needed to finish their story there's a
reason why they've liked it we're not
doing a matrix for because we told the
story we wanted to tell it was complete
there it's done for them yeah well
everything I remember about the matrix
like the media that sprung off the
matrix it seemed like everybody always
wanted to be there like you know like
you said cash grabbing yeah it's like
those three movies say what you will
about the quality of the second and the
third one you can't fault them for you
know laziness or for not you know
putting a lot of effort and a lot of
care into that my first thought when I
heard this you know which Alex Keyes had
to do the movie bound first they have to
show they can direct and if you haven't
seen bound that's a great [ __ ] movie
though which house keys that bound first
a show they can direct so they could do
their baby project their dream movie the
matrix so it wasn't like hey you got an
idea yeah let's pitch you an idea okay
we'll write it in a few months and get
it to you they work years on the matrix
this wasn't this wasn't like hey well
it's greenlight a matrix project alright
let's hire someone to write the script
for it it wasn't just some Hollywood
turnout film it was this was a baby
project for the Wachowski yeah so if
anything has to be involved now let's
let's move on to some of the updates
though there's no sort of like a first
initial reaction Zac pen the man who's
writing the treatment I guess I think
he's the one who's gonna be writing the
whole film actually is he related to
Sean and Chris Penn irrelevant at this
point yes he tweeted out a few things
that put some of my concerns services I
had some ideas where I was like if he
should I don't think you should do a
sequel if anything you should do some of
these things
if you're gonna do a continuation of the
matrix world the universe and he said
some things that help me feel like okay
they're going something like they might
be going a little bit more along the
lines of what I was thinking they could
do all I can say at this point is no one
could shoot no one could or should
reboot the matrix people who know Hana
matrix which is [ __ ] awesome and the
comics understand can't comment yet
except to say of the words reboot and
remake were from an article let's stop
responding to better recast Keanu Reeves
I would cast Keanu Reeves thank you do I
want to see more stories set in the
universe of the matrix yes because it's
a brilliant idea that generates great
stories look oh people are doing the
x-men universe between Logan and Legion
and Deadpool's anyone want them to stop
not me a couple ideas I was pitching to
John that I was thinking they could do I
don't think option B would be this but
if I would have much rather prefer them
just to continue matrix four and five
beyond doing a prequel because the way
the Matrix Revolutions ends it ends in a
way where it's the first time if you
guys remember the crazy details of the
Matrix movies in reloaded the Arctic
explains that this is the matrix just
plays out it constantly resets itself
we're watching the sixth version I think
play out which is the one with neo mr.
Anderson and Trinity resets the one
usually finds feet people to help
rebuild Zion and the program just keeps
restarting like how a computer does a
computer just restarts and it's a
program than just keep anything a start
a computer you know I know this with
editing you have to restart computer and
then a Matrix Revolutions it ends in a
different way than what the architect
was telling him of how it always ends
which is the machines and the humans now
they they have a truce where people can
the matrix can still exist the machines
can use that for their energy but
they're not gonna go and bother people
in Zion anymore like there's you know
let the people as ion live their life
and if anybody's mind rejects the matrix
then they're free yeah now I just use
the people who are good at this I don't
think you should do the matrix unless
the Wachowskis have at least written I
don't think just story credit but I have
written the movies you could get another
director
sure I feel like yeah they have to be
involved in the actual creative part of
the Emily script format for sure here's
where it's a story
yeah because The Matrix Revolutions ends
in a way were this they don't know how
it's gonna play out now
yeah people of Simon don't know neo is
dead but the program of neo can still
live on because that's what the
Merovingian is we'll go into that in a
second so yeah it's like it doesn't
really end in a way that we all thought
it would end which is they just Inhumans
destroy the machines now and everyone's
freed from the matrix but how crazy
would it be if it started going down
that path or like we really can't trust
the machines right yeah I feel like they
could continue that journey there cuz
it's a neat ending to have it be where
there's where now it's a truce cuz it's
like how the [ __ ] could you pull that
off in a movie where they awakened
everyone from the main that's just a
hole that you have them out in the real
world okay there are no reasons or
safety structures I could see a sequel
more than a prequel because the [ __ ] is
a prequel Morpheus gonna be him just
forming a team of the Nebuchadnezzar I
know this is tank ooh this is cypher oh
this is what cypher was like a rigid
like a lot of those like things I know
they're all going to agree at some point
so if their reasons for not agreeing now
are ya telling is hell I wouldn't want
to see prequel movies like that like
they're describing but I don't think a
prequel is impossible you just have to
like I think that's something cool we
learned from row one is like oh if you
just go back in time to a crucial moment
and tell that story so like you know in
that sense if you wanted to do like beta
matrix one thing or like the first mate
like here's how the Society of humans
fell into the matrix system like the
crucial moment where that happened like
sure it's not as marketable of an idea
cuz it's not all the same [ __ ] that we
know but like I think that could be a
cool place that could be compelling for
sure you know and that's you know we're
you can always tie that in to what's
going on in life right now because our
tech is getting better and always our
relationship with technology like you
know you could do cool philosophical
[ __ ] with that too so I'm not I don't
think it's impossible but I definitely
don't want matrix Cinematic Universe
everybody's got their own franchise we
all get together
the machines like well what he was
saying what Zach pen was saying was
going off an idea that I think could
work which is if anything just explore
different areas the world still exists
Xion exist in earth so there's probably
other areas of Earth as well you know
other problems other other problems in
the matrix what I was thinking was one
of them one of the more fascinating
parts of the movie to me which a lot of
people the first time they watched The
Matrix Reloaded think it's kind of
pointless but really it's alluding to
what the architect will reveal by the
end of Matrix Reloaded which was
Merovingian and Monica Bellucci I don't
know the actor's name of the Merovingian
I don't really character Dana Monica
Bellucci
yeah because one thing that the Oracle
explains in the Matrix Reloaded is that
programs live in exile and what we learn
from if you pay close attention to the
movies is the Merovingian and monica
bellucci they're essentially former neo
and former Trinity from earlier versions
of the matrix because that's why he kind
of just dressed like the one actually
and a lot of what they're saying is
alluding to that and that's why Monica
Bellucci has that long makeout scene
with neo because she wants to feel like
Trinity again they're just there
programs that still exist with the Exile
programs that still live within the
matrix but they've grown to like hate
each other and resent the matrix and now
they live in like the darkness of
they're like [ __ ] let's give in to
the darkness I felt like if there was if
there's like a prequel thing you could
do I would love to see the Merovingian
story of when he was the one and then
when he had to make that choice of go
save his woman or help rebuild Zion and
how he and what that repercussion does
and what how the relationship is forming
and you could see what it's like when
they have to rebuild Zion and everything
and what how he now lives in the matrix
and really explore that so I felt like
that would be a cool universe idea or
yeah whose explore more of the universe
I don't think an ego sequel or prequel
but I think exploring universe could
work but it still has to offer something
we're in more than a
cool flick it has to give us like oh now
there's even more meaning and more
deeper understanding in the matrix and I
mean you know honestly like I don't
think the matrix is something you just
can't ever touch you know like I just
again I think you need a good reason to
do it because you could do all kinds of
things with the matrix now I mean you
could do you know the Animatrix is
essentially an anthology that's just
kind of a lot of short yeah but you
could do you know an anthology diversion
the matrix hop around in different
places or you could you know tell I like
what Zack Penn's talking about here I
have no idea what that's gonna look like
but you know especially when you pointed
out movies like Logan and Deadpool and
yeah the show Legion and stuff like it
seems like yeah you could take this as
an opportunity to bring the matrix back
do some interesting style stuff and also
you know I was thinking about earlier
part of what helps the matrix become
iconic was not only was it like
mind-blowing and cool but they also
innovated and like use new technology
like created a trend in the cinema so
there's a lot you can do on all levels
and I feel like if you're gonna bring
the matrix back you should do that
absolutely
get a badass story or if you don't just
want to do three movies with a really
thick story choose some other format
that makes you able to get heady
but also get cool this could be like a
sci-fi black mirror if we just want to
keep it going you know totally a fantasy
we're more of a fantasy you know
consistent fantasy oh yeah telling like
conversation provoking sci-fi stories
with [ __ ] awesome action in like
state of the art like tech and the
matrix world has constantly been
expanded for me and beyond it's movies I
mean the videogame you enter the matrix
and then because you mention Animatrix
and enter the matrix - it kind of has an
idea that Zach Penn sounds like he's
sort of talking about here where enter
the matrix is all about what Naomi was
doing during reloaded because we don't
see her a lot in the movie but it's all
about here's what she's doing they
filmed actual scenes for clips for the
game - it wasn't just computer-generated
CGI game graphics it was actual scenes
they filmed just for the video game I
think yeah and there's some matrix
comics - that the witch house keys were
involved in this is something where the
universe could totally be explored
don't think you need to do a pretty cool
I think if you do sequels please bring
back things like casts that we love we
don't need a cipher spin-off I still
want to make like my 90's action movie
about cipher like I don't know you could
it would be neat to see if they would
crash on their genres and stuff into
this I don't know nothing should happen
to the matrix just because it sounds
cool yeah like that's that's the bottom
line I just feel that the matrix is more
than just plot and cool characters it's
got cool this one of those movies that
has every people still theorized what
the [ __ ] the matrix means yeah like even
not long ago film theory did this great
video that everyone was talking about
about how Agent Smith was really the one
and I watched it and I was on a huge
matrix fan and I was like we know we
know which house keys that might be true
all right what do you guys think in the
matrix reboot should they do it prequel
and doesn't sound good to you
reboot what do you say Manchester what
kind of story would you like to see if
you're new to the channel subscribe to
the real rejects reasons Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum house and the real
rejects shout out to Keanu goodbye my
now come I know